a lot of doctors a kid will present and
say doctor i think i'm transgender and
the doctor feels unqualified to handle
that kind of thing and so the doctor
thinking that she or he is doing the
right thing makes a referral to the
experts or the gender clinic they think
that's appropriate it's like when i was
18 um i was anorexic and i saw my doctor
and my doctor referred me to
a eating disorder clinic right that's
just sort of how things work and i'm
very happy to say that that was
effective and i stopped being anorexic
so that's good but that's that's what
these doctors are doing they're
referring kids to gender clinics
thinking they're doing the right thing
and the people who run the gender
clinics i do not think are motivated by
good motives at all i think these are
horrible people who are paid to ruin
people's lives
wow okay
okay so once a kid starts these what
what happens if they change their mind
like i've seen people online where
they were kind of influenced by their
peers and they thought it was the cool
thing and that's what they believed at
the time and then they get to be 21 and
and they're like okay
that was wrong i don't want that anymore
what do those people do
so in theory it's possible to stop
uh after having taken puberty blockers
um the long-term effects of puberty
blockers by themselves are not known so
we don't know for example if it's ever
possible to stop taking puberty blockers
and then have a normal puberty i've
heard people say it is possible and i've
heard people say it's not possible wow
but we part of the reason we don't know
that is that almost no one takes puberty
blockers for a few years and then stops
the vast majority of kids that go on
puberty blockers go on to take opposite
sex hormones the vast vast majority go
on to take opposite sex hormones um and
those are
absolutely not reversible there's no
question about that
and yeah we're seeing a lot
a lot of young people mostly in their
20s having gone through all of this and
now they they want to go back but
they're not reversible so
these young people often have to go
through sort of
psychological torture to realize what
they have put themselves through
sometimes with the permission of their
parents
you know always with the permission of
their doctor
and often
being encouraged by their
therapists and
we have a lot of young women these days
with a lot of artificially lowered
voices because they can't get their
voices back once they've been on
testosterone a lot of women
have had double mastectomies and
will never have their natural breasts
back
and people sort of brush that off and
say well they can just get synthetic
ones and it's like how are we here
how on earth are we here um and it's
there are plenty of boys and young men
who are going through this as well it's
just much more prevalent in young women
because it's young women who are being
pressured into this
more than boys and that's not to say i
lack sympathy for the boys who are going
through this of course i have tremendous
sympathy for boys
you know how how graphic do you can can
we be here no be graphic people should
know what's going on like this is awful
i mean there are young men who have had
their testicles and penises removed
and um
you know to go through regret for having
done something like that i i don't know
i'm not a guy but it just
i just so feel for these young people
who were pushed into something as
dangerous as
st and and these kids are being
sterilized i mean we can't forget that
we're having young people make the
decision to be to sterilize themselves
um
kids who can't buy alcohol are making
the decision to sterilize themselves and
i think it's outrageous so i really feel
for these young people who are
realizing what happened to them
and they're trying to get their lives
back